un círculo tiene una circunferencia de
10 centímetros un arco x en este círculo
tiene un ángulo central de 260 grados
cual es la longitud de x vamos a
visualizar lo que sucede voy a dibujar
un círculo lo mejor que pueda al menos
para que se den una idea este es el
círculo y este su centro tiene una
circunferencia de 10 centímetros por lo
que para recorrer todo el círculo
tenemos que la circunferencia es de 10
centímetros también hay un arco x que
tiene un ángulo central de 260 grados
vamos a dibujarlo si llegamos hasta aquí
tenemos 90 grados si llegamos acá
tenemos 180 grados y si llegamos hasta
aquí tendríamos 270 grados ya nos
pasamos por lo que este ángulo estará
por aquí este es el ángulo central de
260 grados vamos a dibujar su arco
correspondiente con otro color
este es el arco x del que queremos
calcular su longitud pensemos lo de esta
forma su ángulo central es de 260 grados
cuál es el ángulo central de la
conferencia la circunferencia es toda la
vuelta que son 360 grados por lo que la
fracción del arco x con respecto a toda
la circunferencia va a ser la misma
fracción que el ángulo central con
respecto a 360 grados la circunferencia
mide 10 centímetros y la fracción de
esta circunferencia que corresponde a x
será la misma fracción que el ángulo
central que tiene este arco con respecto
a toda la circunferencia que es de 360
grados son 260 360 bosch de la
circunferencia a que va a ser igual
podemos simplificar esto un poco si
dividimos el numerador y el denominador
entre 10 tenemos 10 entre 10 es igual a
1 permítanme escribirlo de esta forma
260 por 10 pi es igual a 2600 pi entre
360 y ahora si simplificamos dividimos
el numerador y el denominador entre 10
esto es 260 y esto es 36
y parece que el numerador y el
denominador son divisibles entre 4 260
entre 4 es 200 entre 4 es 50 y 60 entre
4 es 15 15 más 50 es igual a 65 por lo
que el numerador es 65 36 entre 4 es 9
esto lo trató de hacer mentalmente
porque es bueno practicarlo pero podemos
hacerlo a mano si dividimos el numerador
y el denominador entre 4 es 260 entre 44
caben 26 6 veces 26 menos 24 es 2
bajamos el cero y cuántas veces cabe 4
en 20 cada vez 5 veces 5 por 4 es 20 20
- 20 es 0 esto es lo que hicimos aquí 65
pi entre 9 parece que no podemos
simplificar más por lo que al ver las
opciones nos encontramos que la tercera
opción coincide con esto que acabamos de
calcular lo que es bueno elegimos esta
opción